[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt
heute gibt es ein leckeres österliches
rezept und das mache ich nicht alleine
ich habe mir gedacht wenn der mourad
meghni backen kann kann ich auch mit
meiner freundin button sind kaum herein
hallo hallo du dabei so kann ich nicht
arbeiten ich brauche es okay ist kann es
darum weniger minuten handeln was hätte
ich bin bereit was man heute eigentlich
brötchen gebacken brötchen
yes we can ja aus einem tontopf und dann
machen wir noch butter dazu bella mutter
wenn der murat ballack bekommt und dann
gibt es noch kleine frischkäse welchen
sie sehen aus wie kleine küken pro woche
sind ja ich bin vorbereitet
kommen
[Gelächter]
und ja also wir uns gedacht
brötchen aus einem tontopf beim weg auf
verspürt und kleine frischkäse küken ja
und dann schön aufs brot schmieren und
leider auch guter weil gerade weil
laufzeit ist das rezept von dass mein
lieblingsrezept weiß auch ich liebte es
vor allem sonntags mache ich immer gern
baguette geht so war schnell den treffer
nicht gelten sondern einfach nur und
daraus machen wir uns heute die brötchen
und die tontöpfe die habe ich bereits
gekauft im bauma und tonia ein ganz
natürliches produkt und die tonmeister
hab ich schon gekauft die können wir
einfach war auch spüre ich sag ich mal
kurz die zutaten für den hefeteig hast
du mich
für den hefeteig nehmen wir fünf gramm
trockenhefe oder zehn gramm frische hefe
einen teelöffel zucker 300 milliliter
warmes wasser 380 gramm mehl da haben
wir ein dinkel mit 630 eineinhalb
teelöffel salz etwas pfeffer und einen
teelöffel kurkuma ich kann dich so nett
ein schlimmer warum habe ich was die
zähne oder was liebe stifter also gut
das war ein einfaches konzept ausgesucht
haben wir nehmen jetzt trockenhefe weil
der murat vergesse frische hefe zu
kaufen und bei trockenhefe einfach immer
die hälfte das heißt bei einem würfel
hefe 172 gramm nämlich 20
trockenhefe sind zwei päckchen jetzt
nämlich zehn gramm frische hilfe oder
findest gramm trocken heesen ich nehme
zwar gute runde daheim hat weil manchmal
haarscharf elektrische hilfe oder ich
friere einfach eine hilfe 1 beim zucker
rheinwasser schneebesen kurz verrührt
und das ding hast du mir mitgebracht aus
der mühle oder dinkelmehl was ist der
unterschied wurde ist ein gekreuzte
weizen also ein richtig original und
salz und dann immer noch kurkuma dann
bekommst du schöne farbe und früher
dachte ich ja ich mache das immer mit
dem mixer echt ja
[Musik]
dinkelmehl und weizenmehl also denken
wir jetzt auch ein bisschen mehr
flüssigkeit als weizen anfang an die hna
sozial rausnehmen weil das uns wieder
alle ernst
ich muss kurz einen schrecken ich muss
ich muss jetzt wird das seriös wäre das
geht sowohl steinbrecher produkten
ja ich habe jetzt noch ein bisschen
wasser dazu gegeben denn weizenmehl
brauchen wir weniger flüssigkeit und
denke mir braucht einfach bisschen mehr
flüssigkeit und der teig ist perfekt
wenn er so aussieht so halb flüssig hier
schon so ein bisschen also weiter als
normaler hefeteig einfach mit dem teig
verrühren
oder wie hier ist ein mix an emma und
das war es schon also kein kleben so
sieht super aus und ich habe ich echt
richtig richtig schön und jetzt lasst
mit dem hefeteig einfach stehen zu zwei
stunden abgedeckt
dann bildet ein richtig schöner bürger
bläschen und so entsteht auch immer das
magische baguette und exakte projekt
genau auf ihre decke okay hier nicht
in der zwischenzeit kann man schon mal
die frischkäse bändchen machen und murat
losschicken für die berner bärlauch für
die frisch gekürten verwenden wir
frischkäse in dem rahmen stufe geschälte
mandl etwas kummer und später für den
schnabel und für die füße eine karotte
also gemacht haben es noch nicht aber
wir haben sie uns schon mal so ausgemalt
im kopf ich denke es klappt auch ganz
gut wenn jetzt die mantel und damals
halt die geschälten genommen dass man
eben eine schöne helle farbe haben
kurkuma carey wird auch gehen aber
carroll dunkler und natürlich
geschmacksintensive wenn man es mag
kumar ist das auch ganz tolle
heilpflanzen ja einfach so ziehen
frage ich bin gespannt wie schön das
reichte liebe kommt oma da kommt mir die
farbe auch die habe und der duft
wahnsinn so schön
[Musik]
jetzt probieren wir das mal
ich nehme jetzt ein eis portioniert und
kann mir immer die gleiche größe hey ich
weiß nicht was jetzt in der hand vorm
oder direkt und indirekt reinschmeißen
genau dann vielleicht genau bisschen so
grenze und werden am besten mit kugeln
wenn sie hier klappt klappt kommt das
machen wir jetzt
dann habt ihr wirklich schön fürs
osterfeuer oder auch noch so fürs
frühlings befehl einfach schöne fügung
wenn man sich dann kalt stellen
die yamaha fazer darin fest 8
als portionierer ich bei mir so ich
portionierer alles außer eis ich habe
tatsächlich keinen und und jedes mal
wenn ich ihn braucht angestrengt
das könnte man im prinzip ja aber mit
anderen farben machen eine flasche zum
beispiel mit grünem drin doch rot
paprikapulver ja ich finde für ostern
dekorieren
das ist nicht mal was was jetzt noch mit
ostern zu tun hat sondern einfach
frühlingsgefühlen genau frühlingsgefühle
wecken modell erst ganz kurz an die
schublade denn nicht glaube ich mache
das so ich hoffe jetzt dünne karotten
scheiben liegt nicht drin
man schneidet daraus kleine dreiecke und
dann gibt es das schnabel
[Musik]
aber ich schneid jetzt hier vorne erst
mal am dreieck
so eine raute schneiden nach vorne
ansetzen
[Musik]
man könnte jetzt zwei machen da wirklich
so dass schnabel geöffnet
[Applaus]
walter beim globus
aber im wald kann man das auch für
talent muss man halt aufpassen
ja ja woher weiß schon ist man schön war
gestern im wald morgen war sieht man das
ist schon kilo gewann gegen duman gewalt
immer sonntag sonntag
man muss nur aufpassen also interview
ich habe was haben sie getan hat babys
sie war auch dass sich da müssen wir
aufpassen er war beim bärlauch da muss
man aufpassen denn michael ist sich
genau diesen giftig sind mit dem
pharmahandel woran erkennt man das dann
auf salafist wenn da nicht drin ist kein
wert auf ja und wenn aber auch keine
gelaufen ich kann es nicht genau weiß
nicht warum sind gleich aus ich habe die
schule gelernt ihr könnt ja nicht
michael ballack lücke gehen lange grün
dann danke liebe bella und vor allem als
bella hat den vorteil
es schmeckt wie knoblauch riecht aber
naja man redet ja ihr könnt weitermachen
wir machen hier weiter ist wie lang ich
war also wirklich ganz wichtig beim
bärlauch lücken immer dran riechen
maiglöckchen sind vergiftet
zumal unsere küchen die sind echt süß
aus und wir haben jetzt hier so kleine
pfefferkörner gefunden
und die gibt's jetzt als augen bekommen
aber dass wir gleich groß sind die
beiden seien stets außerhalb wird china
ich weiß noch nicht mal ein bisschen ja
versucht es mal an dem flüsschen regnitz
mal bis in die küche und wie man hätte
auch ein
sowas macht man nicht jeden tag aber ich
bin für spanisch mit der familie schon
besonders hier
ich habe jetzt das so mal probiert so 2
direkt nebeneinander
ja ein bisschen
du musst halt machen dass das aussieht
wie 2 du musst praktisch in der mitte
zuerst den strich dann ein bisschen was
aus der mitte weg und dann halt das
andere nur noch halbieren
dann sieht es aus wie zwei nebeneinander
das sieht also ein paar hütten sind
paarhufer
[Musik]
sein ja mal siehst oder deshalb ein
stummel fuß weil wir mal zwei einzelne
füße macht dann verliert gleich und ein
ganzes genre also hier ein ganzes
schneiden dann hier unten halbiert
das ist aussieht wie 2 christian was aus
der mitte weg dann stets auseinander und
dann hier die zweifler rein ich weiß es
ist biologisch bisschen falsch aber es
sieht so gemacht die alge oder macht
schon noch für drei stück nur noch für
die pfeiler futter verwenden wir 250 g
weiche butter 100 gramm verlauf hier
habe ich ein gewitter zusammen gemischt
aus salz pfeffer und knoblauch granulat
und ein bisschen zitronen abrieb so
machen wir die stängel weg bärlauchpesto
habe ich übrigens schon pesto ist auch
richtig lecker und bärlauch gibt es ja
leider nur zwei bestimmten saison jetzt
gerade
daher muss man jetzt diese ausnutzen
aber die butter wir machen jetzt eine
große menge also eine relativ große und
die könnt ihr dann eigentlich einfrieren
in kleinen gläschen und man schmeckt ja
auch kein unterschied also wirklich
perfekt und dann habt ihr immer was da
noch geht
[Musik]
bisschen zu thronen april noch eine
prise gerne mehr braucht noch ein
bisschen haut vor mir das ganze ein
bisschen frischen bärlauch butter
ich brauche nichts mehr als dieses brot
und werden auch futter das reicht mir
zum frühstück so dann nehme ich das
gebührt selbst zusammengemischt und das
ist auch echt toll vor allem wenn man
knoblauch grund mit granulat nimmt dann
riecht man auch nicht ob das stimmt ja
also ich nehme jetzt deinen toll
gezupften und klein geschnitten und
werden auch nicht wunderschön dekorativ
kommt ja alles rein mit einem stabmixer
kleibers
so ich nehme ich einmal in spritzbeutel
und so habe ich hier vorne so eine
stelle und damit können wir die kleine
häufchen spritzen und damit aber auch
noch kleine gläschen führen und
einkehren
aber kann beides super vorbereiten
ich nehme es hier einfach so eine dauer
back folie auf ein kleines backblech
weil das passt einfach gut in meinen
gefrierschrank also normalerweise wenn
ich die mutter macht ja du auch gleich
vielfach von der menge und ein gefrieren
sofort ein trennen wenn man sich schon
einmal die arbeit macht dann kommen auch
direkt zum großen mixer nehmen und schön
alles fein pürieren und gibt es halt
nicht so oft das ganze nur wie lange
vier wochen lösung für den jahrelang so
manche sagen beim einfrieren verliert
sich der geschmack ab je mehr was will
man sonst machen entweder hat man es
eingefroren oder halt gehabt
und ich glaube zu den küken passt ganz
gut dieses kleine häufchen nebendran
nein das war musste es sieht aus wie st
und dann fehlen jetzt noch ein paar
gläschen so kleine gläschen die könnte
natürlich auch ganz schön verschenken
jacke schon ein schönes mitbringen sagt
born
[Musik]
und zum grillen schmeckt die mutter auch
gut zum fleisch schmeckt immer ist mir
gut zu allem wirklich zu allem gut und
wenn man möchte könnte man die butter
übrigens auch noch mit dem schneebesen
aufschlagen da wird so richtig schön
locker sondern lockerer tonfall
schlöffel aber es ist okay jetzt kurz
ein und sobald die zwei stunden vorbei
sind kann man die brötchen fährt genau
wenn man das hier ein film ja angst du
bist so sieht der teig jetzt aus es
sieht richtig schön aufgegangen schön
viele blogger bläschen und wir haben
jetzt hier diese tontöpfe die haben
jetzt einfach aus dem baumarkt ton ist
wirklich ein ganz natürliches material
mache ich auch immer im römertopf
gebacken und zwar auch einen tontopf sie
haben im ausgewachsenen wieder trocknen
lassen und iris hat jetzt grad mit
traktoren spray gerettet und ja man dann
einfach aus packpapier kleine kreise
zugeschnitten dafür einfach den ton
druckauftrag papier gelegt mit einem
stift entlang gezeichnet und
ausgeschnitten also ganz genau muss es
nicht sein dass da geht es im prinzip
nur darum dass dieses loch in der mitte
nämlich gestoppt wird so das heißt durch
mit ihrer show vorbereiten also einmal
gerettet
dann kommt das papier ein schön glatt
und dann wird es nochmal gefettet damit
einfach wirklich alles komplett genau
alles voll ist jetzt gebe ich ein
bisschen mehr noch ein gefühl jetzt den
teig mit nein
[Musik]
ich fülle die jetzt so etwa bis 2 cm
unter den rand denn das geht echt noch
gebaut
so sehen sie jetzt aus echt schön jetzt
schon schön ich bin gespannt wer jetzt
kommen sie in den vorgeheizten backofen
bei heißluft 240 grad ich mache das
ganze jetzt mit dampf stoß weil sobald
ich auch das paket immer du aufgabe und
so wird auch das paket immer wirklich
schön kross außen schön fluffig und
saftig ihnen ihr könnt aber wenig keinen
dampf backofen habt einfach ein
schälchen mit kochendem wasser mit den
backofen stellen dann hat man nämlich
auch ein bisschen war verdammt
also ich hoffe die gehen jetzt wirklich
wunderschön auf und dann sehen wir uns
nach dem backen wieder
[Musik]
amanda schön geworden
mein gott jetzt sind die tolle
aufgegangen und es riecht so lecker und
wirklich mal kann ich meine das ist
wirklich super einfach diesen tag zu
machen macht einfach gleich eine
vierfache menge aber auch keine brötchen
kaufen für das oster brunch oder fürs
frühlings brand richtig gut
ach wie schön und dann glaube ich wo ist
mit holzbrettern werden doch ein
holzbrett nochmal das hin- oder im
schönen teller
ich glaube die sind meist ein heiß oder
ok nur geht dann zwar auf dem teller
will probleme was uns besser gefällt
frischkäse butter dieser gefroren die
kann man normalerweise ist ein
unternehmen guckte mal der teller ist
schöner gelb ich möchte dazu dass hier
was ist das moor adel ist es nicht süß
mehr braucht man nicht immer mal laden
noch perfekt das frühstück als berater
weiter ich weiß noch aus
wenn man hier oben einfach so rein ins
brot und dann nur der ikano verfügt
ausgesagt kleines pflänzchen oh mein
gott ist das möglich nach films ja so
was mal probieren wir probieren das
angerichtete das lassen aber für unser
foto
also ich bin gespannt wie sie sich
herauslösen lassen
ein bisschen abkühlen lassen ja wir
lassen uns noch kurz abkühlen war doch
so ein bisschen heiß aber es geht
herr studios unser leckeres brot und das
riecht lecker nach gott nach kuba so ich
mag bellach butter du ich schlimm
bärlauch butter und und frischkäse und
frischkäse die butter dann einfach
rechtzeitig aus dem tiefkühlfach nehmen
wenn sie wieder relativ schnell weich
bei uns ist immer ein bisserl hart denn
unsere brötchen nicht das recht so gut
traum mehr brauchen wir da wäre ist
jetzt brutal das küken von hinten nach
vorn
wir arbeiten uns um hilfe
da
das ist auch gut so
perfekt so gut wirklich probiert gerne
mal aus beuern oster oder
frühstücksbuffet für den brunch super
lecker ihr könnt natürlich auch den teig
mit also wäre es jetzt mit kuba gemacht
ihr könnt auch gewürze mit dazugeben
chili rein getrocknete tomaten wahlloser
oliven oliven alles was ihr gerne habt
probiert das rezept gerne aus auf sallys
- doch der findet erst ich finde dass
das eine hübsche idee vor allem wenn er
eingeladen seit oder auch gäste zu euch
bekommt probiert's aus markiert uns und
dann sehen wir uns wieder beim nächsten
mal das boot geht übrigens einfacher aus
dem förmchen heraus wenn ihr das ganze
förmchen mit backpapier belegt dafür
nehmen wir euch einfach ein stück
backpapier und gefaltet zur mitte hin
wie eine tüte dann die höhe aus lassen
wir außen wegschneiden
ausgrenzung fetten
und das spart papier einlegen und ein
bisschen am rand entlang drücken
[Musik]
und ihr könnt ihr schreiben auf das
format gefallen das war vielleicht die
iris öfter was für ein kopf zu mir die
kerne gerne wahr gemacht dass sie so
aufgeregt war ich aber warum denn ja
romanstoff gerät
es gab auch sein problem ist ich hab
kein problem
war gut mit dir danke tschüss
[Musik]
[Applaus]